[Music]  the myth is that as the agribusinesses  benefit the community's benefit how's  the water at the school do you guys  drink the water at the school it tastes  like blood but in case of the Resnick's  even with their you know slideshow ready  charity no you see that the Resnick  you know jump up the Forbes list of  billionaires and the workers can't even  drink the tap water  and the ironies couldn't be sharper  because the California Aqueduct  literally flows through town delivering  high quality dirt cheap subsidized  Northern California rainwater to the  fields of paramount farming  [Music]  but it's not an aberration in the system  it's the whole model it's not designed  or geared to build communities and to  treat people well it's designing gear to  make money  [Music]  [Music]